however screwed up California is it
would be a lot more screwed up if people
weren't allowed to leave hi i'm tim
cavanaugh from raisin TV we're here with
Peter Thiel the American entrepreneur
and investor thank you for joining us
thanks for having me
you were an early investor in facebook
and the facebook Olivia's just come out
I was wondering if you could speak it
all about the accuracy of the movie not
just in the story that it tells but in
the sociological assumptions about how
you know new media are changing us
whether number of factual inaccuracies
about the movies it certainly portrays
the people in a much worse light than I
know them having worked with the number
of these people for the last six years I
think there it's an incredibly dedicated
awesome team of people that has created
tremendous value for themselves their
investors and the world at large where I
think the movie is most wrong is in sort
of imposing a Hollywood view of reality
Hollywood is old of a zero-sum game you
know there can only be so many
celebrities and everybody's sort of as
is always on trying to edge everybody
else out whereas I think Silicon Valley
in technology is fundamentally about
creating a win-win where everybody can
do better and that's I think that's sort
of it tries to impose a Hollywood or
governmental win-lose mentality on a
world that's fundamentally about winning
and winning that being said I think the
one very a positive thing about the
movie is that it is going to encourage
in spite of the worst intentions of the
producers and people involved in
creating it in spite of their worst
intentions it will encourage a lot of
people to go into the tech industry in
Silicon Valley so I think on that it's a
very positive thing
are we not past this point of you know
technology is going to turn us all into
automaton
and it's taking away our privacy and all
that kind of study the sort of
fear-mongering the EC and holiday it's
hard to judge exactly where we are in
society and thinking about technology my
hope is that technology is able to
accelerate on its own and it's freed
from political constraints I do worry
that if we had an up or down vote on a
number of technological areas people
would actually just vote against it I
think the political consensus in our
society is is not very friendly towards
scientific or technological progress and
it's not what people think of as as the
indispensable ingredient for for
creating a more prosperous world in the
decades ahead PayPal was initially
viewed and sort of you know have highly
utopian I mean maybe not by you but but
by the the world has sort of a you know
a possibility of revolutionising the
whole money system and all that kind of
thing does the actual PayPal experience
indicate that there there is no escape
from the government and from the dollar
system and it's it's not easy to escape
certainly certainly the regulatory
issues surrounding the payment monetary
system are formidable I would say at the
same time that I think we are heading
towards a world where people have
somewhat more control over their money
and they did 30 or 40 years ago and and
one macroeconomic way of describing this
is the way of seeing lower and lower
rates of inflation it's getting harder
for governments to inflate away I
believe even Zimbabwe in the last year
is basically dollarized
and so it's now the US dollars are legal
tenders and exchange in Zimbabwe and
even though we have all sorts of
concerns about the dollar being sort of
a paper form of money from the point of
view of people living in Zimbabwe
probably is a big improvement which is
is interesting because it's you know as
everybody knows it's not backed up by
anything it's just a and you know it's
mostly its the authority of the
government is backed it up but it's
really the consensus of people in
Zimbabwe and all of these other places
where the dollar is basically the
official currency
money is a very strange thing and what
creates monetary values is a very
strange thing without getting into all
the arcane questions about where money
comes from and what it what it really
means I think as a first cut
decentralizing that and giving people
the choice of which currency to use is
probably an important starting point do
do those things come about accidentally
like if California starts issuing IOUs
is there can you say for you know the
six weeks that that's going on this is
actually a competing currency to the
dollar it doesn't seem like as currently
constituted California would be a very
competitive currency especially the IOU
version of it you sure talk about the
seasteading Institute a little bit where
are we and what's your rank are you an
admiral of the ocean sea or I don't
believe I have an official law official
rank on that score the well the goal has
been to to try to create some kind of
space outside of politics I think this
is very very important because I think
there's so much about the political
sphere that's become just poisonous it's
about people collectively hating other
people that's basically with politics
about its collective hatred and and we
need to basically figure out a way to
escape from it I'm personally very
interested in trying to identify some
technological means for escape you can
try to move on to the Internet it's a
question whether that's real you can try
to move to outer space there's a problem
with that being too far away the
technology not quite working and so the
C studying experiment is a bit of an
oven in between of an in-between option
and even if a lot of people do not
actually want to live on platforms in
the ocean or floating ships or floating
cities I think the other option of doing
this the option of opting out of
politics will make it a lot better cover
screw up California is it would be a lot
more screwed up of people
to leave and so I think the freedom to
leave is one of the most fundamental
freedoms not just are we speaking just
about political systems or there you
know and we've seen then maybe this is
something that normal people who don't
really spend a lot of time thinking
about these things don't really see but
you know you're right of exit has vastly
expanded you like to get out of a bad
marriage your right to you know move
from state to state move from country to
country although the United States is
actually pretty punitive about people
leaving the United States these days
United States is not the easiest place
to leave and of course we don't want to
ever have to leave it but in general the
countries that are impossible to leave
tend to be the ones you most like to
leave so probably the hardest country in
the world to leave would be North Korea
and it's probably when people are most
desperate to leave East Germany it was
it was actually perfectly legal to
emigrate from East Germany once you turn
65 years old because at that point you
were seen as a as basically on a net
recipient of state funding until you
were 65 you're basically seen as being
owned by the state and the people who
fled to East Germany they were seen as
basically stealing the state's property
eg themselves you've and one of the
things that people that you're saying
people should be able to leave is
college I think if we won't have a
single discussion of where there's a
bubble in the u.s. it is an education
where more and more money is being spent
on the same or maybe less and less and
so it's in some sense if you define
technologies doing more with less the
things that are anti technological are
the ones where you're doing less with
more or a lot less of the same there's
been more inflation in education than
any other sector of our economy over the
last thirty years and so it's probably
the furthest from technology and
practice one of the problems is that
people end up amassing enormous amounts
of debt in college or graduate school
and then this tremendously constrains
their future options they can not choose
to do things they really want to do or
things that will really transform the
society instead they are too basically
tied to this incredible
a debt and I don't think a society we
should be encouraging or fostering and I
think it's a incredibly inimical to
entrepreneurship which is probably more
critical than ever in this country if if
the government were out of that game by
not providing grants and guaranteeing
loans and so forth would we be better
off would we have seen less inflation we
would seem way less inflation but it's
in the game on many levels we're so far
removed from government being outside of
it that it's it's hard to even know what
that would look like right now we're in
a period of retrenchment with you know
Obamacare and the sort of administration
that's really married to a big
government idea of how to solve problems
yeah we're also seeing a huge backlash
against that in the streets and so where
do you think we are in terms of going
you know an understanding of government
and the function of the state the proper
political debates are where we are in a
surprisingly libertarian moment that's
more so than I would have thought
possible two years ago at the same time
I personally remain rather pessimistic
about how much hope we can have through
merely political means in the long term
it's you know this you see something
very hard about libertarians being able
to win elections and it is not it is not
the preferred choice it is sort of the
last option and maybe it is the last
option we have left maybe maybe you know
everything else has failed but I think
politics becomes libertarian as an
absolute last resort